so today we're going to start with
running through some quick stories in
the first segment and then I'll get to
some of the longer stories I want to
spend more time on later the quick
stories are going to be about all of the
different accusers that are coming out
of the woodwork and saying Donald Trump
did something to me that is or certainly
borders on sexual assault
first and foremost Donald Trump denied a
People magazine journalists claim that
he sexually assaulted her during an
interview by saying she is not
attractive enough for him to sexually
assault her last week I told you that
People magazine journalist Natasha stone
off alleged that Trump tried to forcibly
kiss her while she was on assignment she
wrote that Trump brought her into a room
shut the door and within seconds he was
pushing me against the wall and forcing
his tongue down my throat here is Donald
Trump explaining at a recent rally why
it's just not a believable claim why
didn't they make it part of the story I
was one of the biggest stars on
television with The Apprentice and it
would have been one of the biggest
stories of the year think of it she's
doing her story on Melania who's
pregnant at the time and Donald Trump
our one-year anniversary and she said I
made inappropriate advances and by the
way the area was a public area people
all over the place
take a look you take a look look at her
look at her words you tell me what you
think I don't think so I don't think
you understand the point being made here
Donald Trump seems more embarrassed by
the idea that he be we he would be with
a woman that he sees as not attractive
than the idea that he would sexually
assault a woman if you don't sexually
assault women Pat you don't say I didn't
do it because look at her you say I
don't sexually assault women what he's
saying is that looks are a factor in
determining whether the claim of sexual
assault is more or less likely to be
valid this bottom-feeding nonsense is an
inherent part of trumps character it's
an incredibly embarrassing and of course
the coal campaign is in crisis
management mode yeah but you know his
whole rebuke is that his what he's done
is just words and that Bill Clinton's
done far worse and that Hillary Clinton
because of course she's running yes to
make a point about that enabled these
enabled bill and attacked these women
went after these women sure he's doing
the same thing here now he is doing the
exact same thing attacking their
physical appearance attacking their
credibility attacking their motives etc
etc now of course the Trump campaign
responded by saying Oh Trump was just
saying look at stowing offs words when
he said look at her look at her words he
meant just her words Donald Trump if if
there's one thing that Donald Trump
doesn't do incorrectly its send these
indirect comments in the way that he
wants them to be interpreted when he
says look at her look at her words he is
absolutely saying both things now at
first I thought that the Trump campaign
would be really good for comedy because
he's made Saturday Night Live irrelevant
he's made the onion irrelevant but you
actually can't come up with something
that is sillier than what he does so it
becomes almost impossible to parody the
parodies you see them and you say it's
actually not any crazier or more
outlandish than what Donald Trump has
actually said